the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
why do people save well that seems like
I assume you know the answer to that
well one answer is the economics in a
sense of two standard answers to that
question
one is consumption smoothing consumption
smoothing is the idea what there what's
consumption smoothie right so not have
too much variation in consumption and
what's life cycle
it's another code word of economics used
what's the our life cycle reason to save
yeah so saving for special events in
your life what's the most important
event a lot of people the us save for
one your retirement so I think among
other things saving for you you guys can
revealing your age I guess but its
retirement is the single biggest reason
why people save and that's one life
cycle event which is very predictable at
least if you get there you'll need money
and that's probably and and then as you
said other events you can predict like
you're you know child's wedding own
wedding
childbirth all kinds of other
predictable events any others any other
reason to say
yeah
right the last reason very important
reason is to take advantage of
opportunities bill starting a business
is one what else are us what else could
you do with if you saved up yeah
buying home buying land just paying for
school fees sometimes many many places
you to pay a big part of the school fees
at the beginning of the year so you you
want to have money saved up so that when
this beginning of the year shows up you
can pay the school fees so there's all
kinds of kind of very standard reasons
why people people say so now coming to
why they may not say so sometimes I'm
going to say it's official not to save
people should what are situations where
you shouldn't save
right so one possibility is that today
your marginal utility of consumption is
very high you're sick and you need money
today so you know but let's say on a
more long-term basis is there a
situation where it would make sense not
to save even over five years or
something yeah
another possibility is that it's maybe
you just can't save it's just difficult
high inflation you have to save with
money and so that's makes it you know
you can't you can't say but I'm asking
an even simple question is there or
maybe not simple of a different question
which is imagine that we you could save
there was no problem saving would there
be a situation where you would actually
find it optimal not to save right so one
of one possibility is that you you you
know you you have lots of money now and
the future looks very short you should
not save for sure for sure that's
something important we'll come back to
the yeah right so if if for example you
are in the US Social Security covers a
large part of your earnings if you have
poor and not a large part of your
earnings if you're rich so if you happen
to be quite poor you know that actually
once you turn 65 Social Security is
going to start paying you a fair amount
of money and that's actually let's say
Social Security pays you thirty thousand
dollars a year you're making $20,000 a
year now there's no reason for you to
say right so you you going to Social
Security the government is guaranteed
you $30,000 a year once you retired you
are 62 you are making $2,000 a twenty
thousand dollars a year you have no
reason to say because you know that
actually if you saved you would your
consumption today would go down to let's
say 15 and then your consumption after
retirement will go up to 35 but that
makes no sense you want to actually
smooth you want to so the general
principle what's the general principle
there
much more generally where would you
expect people not to save
right so you're saying there's no way to
say but let's assume there's a way to
save I'm just asking the general
principle from the Social Security
example think about it what's the
general principle when you would you
want to not say
which means what
when you say utility of money decreases
over time what do you what are you
saying about the future you getting
richer if imagine you where someone who
expects to get richer over time a lot
richer over time that person should not
be saving because if I think my wages
are going to grow at 10% a year then I
have no business trying to save because
essentially my consumption tomorrow in
any case will be higher even if I didn't
save any so have no reason to save so if
I think the future is a lot better than
today I should not say that's a general
principle about savings which is that
you're trying to make your smooth
consumption if you tend a smooth
consumption and you know your
consumption is going to be non smooth in
any case then you want to counteract
that by not saving so in general people
who expect so here's a fact I'm not
going to actually spend a lot of time
elaborating on it today at least which
is that the one country the world
what's the country in the world which is
growing the fastest or at least one of
the countries in the world China what is
the book do you know what the personal
savings rate in China is 40 percent so
you know P or 30 percent 30 percent I
think persons have in history so you
think of all these people whose wages
are growing at 10 percent a year or 6 7%
a year are saving are saving 30 percent
of their incomes right now so it's a
very very odd economics are completely
baffled by why Chinese are saving so
much so that's that's sort of it's just
to remind you that this sort of analysis
we went through actually has a very
clear implication which happens to be
false which is that the change in
the Chinese should be not saving because
their wages are going up very fast
our theory clearly said that and we
don't really know why they say so though
we have some theories I might have come
I might come back to that next time but
I want to just keep this general
principle in mind which is that the one
solid reason not to save is you expect
your income to grow a lot whether that
works or not
sorry okay
yeah so that's a good topic to write
Chinese savings is a great topic to
write an essay about okay another reason
people often cite for why people don't
save is they don't have any money how
could they save does that argue and make
sense
when does it make sense
so it's a very common argument how could
the poor save there are many money is
savings primarily about having money
when the so let me put it differently
for two first approximation savings ISM
is about making sure that there is in
the future where I've eaten everything
that I have so if I if I have money
today unless I expect to get richer
tomorrow then even if I'm poor I should
say because it's not about whether I
have money or not
if I'm poor today I'm going to poor
tomorrow then is no different from I'm
rich today I'm a rich tomorrow we have
the same incentives to save we because
what we're trying to achieve is a
efficient division of consumption
between today and tomorrow so the fact
that I pour per se should not imply I
should not but per se say anything about
whether I should save or not but the
savings is about turning you know
trading off consumption today with
consumption tomorrow and that same
trade-off exists whether you poor or
rich you know if I'm poor I still have
to I still have a tomorrow and if I were
tomorrow then I should still save
because you know if I am worried that
tomorrow I'm not going to have any money
that's true for somebody poor and
somebody rich so the fact that I have
little money today
if I'm going to have even less money
tomorrow I should say so it's not about
how much money you have but how much
money you expect to have in the future
that's the same general principle that
we went through in a minute ago having
said that is there a case where being
poor might make you not said what's a
case where these are women kind of
failed
exactly so excellent example so one
reason you even the poor may not want to
save if they really so poor that
tomorrow will not show up if they don't
eat today in that case they have to then
there is no argument for not not say in
for saving because then you know you
would in any case not get there so if
you're desperately poor are you starving
you you probably shouldn't save but if
you're not that poor then the fact that
you don't have income should not matter
so another example many of you already
suggested another argument for why
people don't save is people people just
don't have opportunities to save they
don't have like in you are many of you
suggested inflation so imagine that the
only way I can save is by keeping cash
at home and prices go up
so cash becomes less valuable in other
words there's just no point in trying to
save in that world because you know
you're you're you're in a hyperinflation
or something and you know all your any
money you put away it's gonna be
valueless tomorrow why bother saving so
one our answer to that is that well you
why not put it into a bank account or on
to an investment account so that you
know you you you you buy something
that's investment through inflation
proof why don't you buy a
inflation-proof government bond or
something so there are the assets you
could buy gold so why is it that the
lack of so if used to make the argument
that the poor are particularly
handicapped because let's say they are
they can't access because they don't
have a place to save you have to make
the argument that they have less access
to bank accounts now that's true in the
world it's true it's come
true that the poor have very limited
access to bank accounts most countries
like below 20% of the poor have access
to bank accounts so that's very true and
if you take investment accounts or other
money market accounts or other accounts
which are protected again the inflation
that's even more true very few people
have access to them but why is that why
don't the poor have access to bank
accounts why should it be that they have
no access to bank accounts what are our
women's
you know
yes
well they're likewise this
where they are and like let's say
purpose
the banks are interested in community
that the size there
right so that's exactly right so basic
argument is that whenever I want to have
a deposit taking institution anything
any institution that takes your money
once I take your money there is a cost
of that which is kind of fixed and
doesn't entirely scale with the amount
of money so if I am putting in five
dollars and the cost is five dollars to
to take care of your money nobody's
going to willing to do it so you need
enough deposits to make a bank bank work
why is what will be reasons why there's
a fixed cost the fixed cost of banking
well why does banking have a fixed cost
why should it
right so I think what one one version of
that is that banks are required by law
to keep good records of any any deposits
they take and so even if the deposit is
five dollars they can't just say well
we're gonna write this scribble it down
on a piece of paper so basically every
deposit that comes to a bank has to be
recorded in a proper way given that it's
you know somebody has to even if it's
five dollars somebody has to open open a
computer have a computer there open a
computer enter the amount into the
computer send it to someplace so this
there's a lot of reasons why they're
fixed costs of banking and that's the
reason I think that's the single biggest
reason why most poor people don't have
access to bank accounts now the
alternative is to save at home and there
are many reasons why it's difficult to
save at home one has something to do
with inflation you keep your money in
the if you keep money and the prices go
up another problem problem is crime to
keep money at home somebody comes and
takes it it's gone we kept in a bank
it's a banks duty to say keep it safe so
it's that's another reason why you can't
do it and then there are what I'm
calling the self control and spouse
control reasons so self control is you
know if money is if I have money I spend
it if I don't have it
maybe I don't spend it so it's in the
bank it's not in my hand I'm not going
to be able to spend it if it's really in
my pocket I'll just spend it I see
something I want I'll buy it
what spouse control
what do you think what's your guess
right so it may well be that you know
some people in the family might this is
more general than that you you so some
people in the family who have money
might be worried that other people in
the family who don't will come and lay
claims on it so if you have nothing you
can say I have nothing but if not your
husband or your cousin shows up and says
well you know I really need some money I
feel like a drink or I want to buy
something I mean how do you say no to
people so one one one other issue that
arises is that at least you hear a lot
of reports off is people saying that
look I don't keep money at home because
if it does then somebody always shows up
and asks for it and it could be your
spouse could be your brother could be a
friend but if there is a lot of people
who come and ask money from you then you
may actually not want to keep keep money
at home so
now the poor have evolved a lot of
different ways to save one of them is
called a rosca you know the rasca is who
knows what a Roscoe and then what
happened after that so it's no but like
let's say five across Alaska so we all
put in $10 what happens
so exactly so one form of rasca is one
where there's a fixed order we we all
join the rasca we have a lottery and
then a lottery decides the order of
people the you know somebody goes first
somebody goes seconds I'm going to start
somewhere was fourth from fifth let's
say the five people in the rasca now
once you want that set then what happens
is that first day everybody puts in with
say $10 and Mister one gets all of all
of it next next week everybody was $10
and mr. two gets all of it and so so
everybody is sort of in the end
everybody gets tender you know all $50
and they but you know not everybody you
know it's a lottery determines who who
gets it first so if you think of a rosca
what's the Ross what's the advantage of
rasca over just saving at home is there
an advantage
what are the advantages
yeah
so you get your $50 and then you isn't
that a problem so you might you use you
say I have a goal associated with the
money that's then so I'm going to join a
rosca where let's say I would need $50
one of these days then I'm going to join
a rosca
which has the price of $50 that way I
match when I get it I buy it rather than
if I have to save up to $50 they don't
have $5 someday I'll have $42 but not 50
and therefore I still can't buy the
thing I want to buy but I have enough 42
dollars maybe I feel like way I could
spend $2 out of that also some of a pack
of cigarettes or something and and so on
and you you never reach 50 so 1/4 the
fact that there is a matching between
the amount of the rasca and the amount
of what I want to buy is important
that's that's the real one part of the
reason is solved your self-control
problem is because of this magic because
once I have the money I can just spend
it I don't have to you know I need $50
if I have to save up to it
then there'll be a lot of times when I
have less than $50 and I could say well
maybe I'll just spend $2 out of it and
wait another day and put in $2 back and
you never get there whereas this gives
you $50 all $50 all at once and you
immediately spend it so one advantage I
offer it is that it delivers the amount
you want
what's another advantage think of saved
whoa the group of us how long would us
let's say we each need $50 how long
would on average it take us to get to
$50 if we send by ourselves
and we saved they say $10 a week
you were
myself where's that American city and
exactly
so if you save 250 dollars it would take
five weeks for each of you
whereas the expected to delay for
somebody in a rosca is two and a half
weeks because I get it
the mr. one gets it today mr. two gets
it in a week mr. five gets it in five
weeks but he's the last so you bring it
forward by two and a half weeks so it's
it's a it's a large game you immediately
at a large game from from it so that's
that's another big advantage so one is
that it solves the self-control problem
another is that it just brings it
forward towards where you want now
what's up what what you know what a
bidding rasca is
just
right a bidding rasca is instead of
having a fixed order we bid on who's
going to be get it today so you know
after we each put in $10 there's a
bidding opens and one of our whoever
wins
so we basically say that look I'll pay
you know I paid my $10 I'll pay $10
extra to get the $50 and then next week
somebody else would do this you know
maybe he'll say that you know I'll pay
four dollars extra to get the $50 and
then the guy who gets it last
obviously is going to and what was
happening notice is that the part is now
going up so I paid $10 into the pot to
get the extra $10 that can be
distributed among everybody else and so
everybody else is getting paying
actually less to get 50 and if the
person who gets gets it today is paying
more to get the 50 it's a really so
instead of everybody paying 10 can e 50
to get 50 some people are paying 60 and
some people are paying 40 now why would
that make sense what's the advantage of
that why would we want to have a bidding
roster rather than a fixed order
right so you may want to be able to
express your preferences you might be
able to say look I just discovered I
have this opportunity if I buy this bale
of cotton I can produce the shirts and
and sell them for a lot of money I need
the money now so I'm going to step in
and buy I'm going to put in the money
now quickly and if it's worth it's worth
it for me to pay some extra what what's
the advantage of the other so basically
what's the advantage of that towards
others that is effectively like I am
paying interest to other people right
what it walks out to be is if I am
bidding to get it early I'm being more
that's like saying other people are
getting interest on their savings so
they're they're getting they're paying
$10 but I'm actually giving them $10
back so they're getting there then
they're not actually they're getting
some interest on their savings so this
turns it into much more like a bank a
bidding rasca is much more like a bank
because it's it's a way for us to decide
I want the money now I pay extra to
others together so it turns it much more
like a into much more like a bank no we
talked over the advantage of Rosco's
what are the disadvantages what what is
a Roscoe not good for what
yeah
it's also possible that every member has
to save in the same amount at the same
time and so if you have
exactly so two disadvantages one is as
inflexible you do put in ten every time
and that's a you know if your income is
variable you may not want to sell save
ten every time and the other is that
it's it's it's typically short-term so
if you want to self save for retirement
it's not a very good way to get there
because it's it's a it's it's something
that takes you know it's going to end
fairly soon and therefore you you you're
not going to be able to you you're not
going to be able to save for retirement
using it any other disadvantages or
limitations let's say
yeah
right so
the amount in roscas tend to be quite
limited and they're limited precisely by
the fact that it creates an incentive
problem once I've got the money I got my
$50 at that point I have no incentive
stay in the rasca so you need leverage
over me and if there was ten thousand
dollars you may not have that much
leverage over it's $50 so law Rasta seem
to be small that I can save small
amounts or rasca it's gonna be hard to
save a large amount because he's going
to get somebody is going to get very
tempted by it
so one way one other way people save I
remember I I this is what you know the
house I grew up in in in India was built
my grandfather I know whenever my
grandfather used to write like text
books for high school and whenever he
got a contract he would build another
room in the house so the house was like
you know it was the first first rooms
were built in 1939 the last room was
built in 1959 20 years he kept adding
rooms and that was because there were
not very very many good savings products
available and for him it was a very it's
a you know it was something that was all
going to always have value and so he for
him it was a very logical way whenever
he got some money he would Park it into
another room in the house so the room so
if you look the house has every floor
every room in the house has a different
floor you can tell that you know the the
tiles of it that were used to buy you
know for the room one had ran out by the
time we got to room 2 because there was
there was five years later so there was
a different set of tiles or different
flooring so the every room had a
different floor floor a different color
different tile something and that was
and that was very normal in houses
constructed by you know in a particular
period where especially access to
financial assets was very limited so
people didn't have much financially as
they used to save in this way now if you
go to developing countries one thing you
notice is the tons and tons of
unfinished houses like you know just in
the outskirts of any any big city you
see all these houses which are
half-finished
like you know there's like a couple of
walls or or a wall and a roof but then
on the roof there are these still these
you know the these still this pillar
sticking up from the roof and the house
is not pain
doors that's a reflection of exactly the
same fact people are actually building
these houses over time they don't
partly because they don't have good
credit markets so they can borrow to
build a house partly because they don't
have good savings opportunities this is
a perfect way to solve their savings
problem it's they're getting an asset in
the long run and so you know when my
mother had somebody who used to be a
driver car for her and he would like
once in three months take leave and go
build a wall in his house and he didn't
even like build a whole world he would
just have enough money he would save up
enough wanted to build half a wall and
it would go build half a wall then he
show up two days later looking all grimy
because he's been building for two days
then again three months later he'll
built the next wall but now he has a
house he built this whole house he was
and his goal in life was he would not
get married till he had a house so he
he's now got married because he had
postponed his whole here whole marriage
till he could build his own house so his
whole strategy was he would buy a door
these were all investment toward his
marriage so once he got all of that
fixed he went and went and went ahead
and got married so that was like so
that's a classic example when you see it
everywhere and that's one of the you
know it's quite a nice way to say what's
its disadvantage what's a disadvantage
of saving brick by brick what's the
obvious is it one yeah
sorry things could happen to a house
before it's finished that's true
right it's not liquid
it's very illiquid form of savings I
mean you know I
you can't sell usually two walls and a
door so therefore you if you need money
suddenly it's a very bad asset to have
it's a it's a it's a good way if you
knew that there was a future which was
very predictable like this guy who
wanted to get married and he knew that
he you know one day he will need this so
it's very predictable there's an
excellent asset but if you if you
something which is unpredictable then
it's a very bad asset because it's very
illiquid it's like any other illiquid
asset it's now another similar asset
which you see a lot in developing
countries is jewelry you see very poor
people wearing gold jewelry all over you
know yes both India and China you look
at your people even very poor people are
wearing gold having a small a small
piece of jade or something these things
are expensive but again part of the
reason is that they're very good real
assets they they are they don't
inflation-proof gold goes up actually
right now gold is at $1,500 which is
impressive actually I wish I'd bought
some gold last yeah but you know it's
inflation proof it's it's a it's very
divisible you can buy very very small
amounts of it you just buy a pair of
earrings that's not a lot of money you
you you and it's and it's sort of nice
while you have it you get some use value
out of it but you also get lots of you
know it's also something that is and
partly gold is very favored because go
qaulity of gold is cheap to verify this
is why gold was always made into
currency and as a result you get it's
very liquid so if you have a gold
jewelry you can go to the local jeweler
and he'll give you a loan in two minutes
against it it's been
easy to to mortgage basically because
this quality is very well-known you try
to mortgage your house people have to
come and do an inspection figure out if
your house is actually worth anything or
not gold is gold and so a lot of real
reason why so you'll find in very poor
neighborhoods in poor countries a
jeweler and the jeweler is actually
somebody who's constantly giving and
taking money it's a it's a it's a very
much a two-way business he's he's taking
gold and giving money and giving gold
and taking money and it's what goes in
both directions all the time and the
reason why gold is a not gold is
innocence even more attractive asset
than his less use value than the house
obviously houses maybe not but then you
know I don't wear a lot of gold so but
but I suspect he has less use values at
the house but it has a lot more
liquidity it's extremely liquid you can
just take it to the local jeweler you
get money back so and liquid it is
extremely important for the poor because
they they are often like they are often
problems they want to think somebody get
sick you need money
the alternative to all of this is
financial savings of one form or another
some form of financial savings financial
savings are like in assets in banks or
paper assets now these are different
ways to access paper assets even if you
don't have a bank account these are ways
to access paper assets does anybody know
what a money guard is
maybe you want to do their readings a
bit more carefully yeah
yeah money God is some somebody in your
neighborhood who just acts as a bank no
a savings collector how does it differ
from anybody who has to answer that
never they actually visit your house in
regular basis but a small mass savings
collectors typically take it to the bank
so the difference is our savings guard
is someone who keeps it herself
she was depositing this somewhere else
yes but I think I think that it's very
different when the incentives are very
different so imagine that you deposit
all your savings with me and you have no
documentary proof I say well you know
tough I have no idea where it went
what do you do if somebody is putting in
the bank then the maximum they can steal
from you is the today's flaw so if they
put it in the bank then I give it to
them they put it in the bank they get it
stamped in a book so it says if they put
it in a bank I know that essentially all
that they can steal is the amount they
collected today not the entire stock up
to today that they could either put it
in your name or sometimes what people do
is they have to put in let's say ten of
us have to each give you one dollar and
you have to put in ten dollars into the
bank so it's a easy way to check
it's not in their name typically they
can't take it out accounts are such that
it's they deposit into an account and to
take it out somebody else has to
authorize it so they do some so these
are different designs because in some
sense if there's somebody in your
neighborhood is very reliable you can
just give them the money you know
somebody very reliable they can save the
money for you but if it is you don't
have somebody very reliable in your
neighborhood then you often use a
savings collector savings collectors
basically someone who doesn't hold on to
the money and therefore it is much less
liable to you know much less able to run
away with the money
what a service or the self-help groups
yeah
right Purcell for group in a sense is
more flexible than a rosca it basically
makes takes the money whoever gives them
money they take it and then they lend it
to other people within the group or
sometimes what they do is they just
deposit it in a bank that sort of turns
them into a savings collectors so I
think the more yes I guess you're right
you're right
rasca is a type of cell phone but a lot
of cell phone groups are much more
flexible than a rasca they're the Invo
they allow you the option of of putting
the money into you know I put whatever
$2 $1 etc into it the the disadvantage
of so the trade-off between a Rosko and
and a self-help group is the cell phone
group typically the ones that work well
have to have a good accountant roscas
very simple we don't need to know have
any accounting you know that's $10 we
put it in each there's $50 somebody gets
it require zero accounting right
rasca requires zero accounting cell fill
group requires some accounting and
there's some evidence that when the say
the there's no one who can do accounting
they collapse because you basically need
to make sure I'm making a flexible
deposit I'm putting $3 today you put in
five and she borrows seven so if
somebody has to keep track of all those
numbers so and that's much harder if you
are not you know really comfortable with
reading and writing so it's in a sense
it's a rosca is a very specific very
simple form of a cell phone group
whereas simplicity is a huge advantage
because it's it's something that makes
it quite clear you nobody needs to know
accounting to run a rasca whereas to run
a self-help group typically you need to
know some accounting yeah
yeah Alaska is is is a broader category
yeah several group is an example of
something where there is so the
trade-off between so I already answer
the question so if you think of what a
savings collector typically charges
money for it it's somebody who comes in
to your place
collects the money she keeps accounts
for it she's she's a professional she
charges money for it
people pay up to five percent per month
negative interest to get these things so
it's not it's huge so you might might
actually pay someone quite a lot
typically a self L group is one where
you don't get you don't have to pay
anybody it's like like a rosca where the
loss is relatively limited the
constraint is accounting so somebody as
a savings character someone who can
typically in order to keep good accounts
she or even a money guide is someone who
keeps good accounts you go and give her
the money she can show a book where she
keeps exact records or how much you put
in it's not easy to find somebody in
your neighborhood if you're poor who has
good accounting skills whereas if if you
think of and a rock a rasca for example
is beautiful in that it really doesn't
require a lot of accounting as you move
so the trade-off between these come on
how much accounting they requires so
cellphone groups are intensive in
accounting they require that you know we
give track somebody keeps track of who's
putting in money
who's taking out money so if if that's
not being done by a professional then it
depends very much on the quality of the
group if there's no one in the group who
can do the accounting well the group
will collapse if you compare that with
like say savings collectors having
collectors typically what someone's good
at accounting and therefore can be
relied on to do that
job on their own gets paid for it so
that's sort of the trade-off between
these things is that if you have someone
around who is a good accountant who's
part of your group you can have a you
can have a self-help group if you have
someone you're willing to pay someone a
lot to do the accounting for you you can
have a savings collector and if you have
if you have neither you can have a rosca
so rasca is the simplest product is the
most least flexible product but it's the
one that doesn't require any skilled
person to do the job for you so that's
that's the big trade-off between these
things is that some of them rely on
having skilled people around to do the
job others don't
microcredit is another possible savings
instrument how could that be
how could microcredit be a savings
instrument
right so in a sense it's a funny way to
save but you'd be a lot of people saved
that way so you want a television you
can either save let's say car television
cost $200 you can save two dollars a
week for a hundred weeks that's very
difficult
you're $2.00 a week you forget you know
you spend some of the money you're
keeping a lot of money at home the
alternative if somebody gives you to her
to do $200 to buy the television and
then you pay them two dollars a week but
then they charge you some interest you
pay two dollars fifty a week but but
because you paid two dollars or fifty a
week they're willing to give you the
money early a union and then it's their
job to make sure you pay they come and
pester you if you don't pay so it
transfers the burden of repayment and
you know instead of having you having to
do the saving somebody else forces you
to do the saving it's expensive you're
paying twenty four percent a year to get
your you know to save basically it's
like giving up twenty four percent of
your money just to but it has this
advantage that you don't have to you
don't have to wait okay so some little
map so all of this all of this
we've been discussing so I'm going to
we've been sort of going back and forth
and saying well it's difficult for the
poor to save maybe maybe they don't want
to save maybe there's some good reason
why they don't save so we haven't shown
any smoking gun that there is really
inefficiency in savings so I want to
give you an example of how you would
make the reason that there is actually
people actually under save so how would
you make the case that you people under
say so to make this case we'd have to do
a little bit of algebra so let's let's
think about it carefully
okay the first line in that slide is
what's called the Euler equation the
other equation is what is the condition
for savings optimality over time what it
says is the marginal utility of
consumption today how much consumptions
worth to you today should be equal to so
something times margin you do
consumption tomorrow what's the question
being asked
it's asking the question imagine I saved
one more dollar today what would it be
worth tomorrow
well one thing that's gonna be worth is
I'm going to get the interest early so
it's going to be worth 1 plus R the
interest is R I'm going to get 1 plus R
for it yeah but then tomorrow utility
tomorrow isn't worth as much as worth
today
it's like tomorrow it's in the future I
want it now
so that's Delta Delta is a number less
than one so it says that you know
utility tomorrow is worth only a
fraction Delta of utility today and then
the last term is margin you do
consumption tomorrow so basically
imagine that the right hand side of that
is less than the left hand side okay
then what should I do
well I should let me say is that the
marginal utility today is
then what will be worth tomorrow I would
what I should let's do it the other way
round if marginal utility today is less
than Delta times 1 plus R times u prime
city plus 1 that means that one dollar
today
saved will give me more utility than I
would get it today right today I will
get one dollar would give me u prime
city if I saved it I would get 1 plus R
that's gonna be worth Delta u prime city
times 1 plus R so basically I'm getting
more utility by putting money into the
future
so one thing we week so that's standard
condition for consumption optimality the
next line says imagine the utility
function that's a standard form of the
utility function is is that it's it has
that form consumption to the power of
something divided by something it's a
very standard form of the utility
function it's actually you should notice
that even when Sigma is greater than 1
that works
why because C to the or 1 minus Sigma is
then decreasing in C but is divided by a
negative number so it's again increasing
by C so it is it is it works even for
that so if I did that and I substituted
you of CO 2 both sides I would get that
equation in the second line in the third
line the third line comes from the
second line u prime u prime U of C
equals C to the power 1 minus Sigma
divided by 1 minus Sigma I u prime is
then what what's u prime take the
derivative what do you get same idea you
know the answer
come on
all do superior to outside you all feel
like how could you ask me such an inane
question tell me what it is yeah
CT negative Sigma is U prime I put that
into the first equation I get C to the
power and then I use you can see that I
were to get that fourth the fourth line
out of the third line out of that if I
substitute U Prime into that equation
and then I invert that to get the fourth
line now reasonable values of Delta
standard values are like 0.9 that's sort
of people people use that number Oh
point nine point nine five I'm taking a
lower numbered you'll see that a lower
number is going to make it less up mean
if I took the higher number it would by
case will be even stronger Sigma people
think is that a number like two three
four that's the kind of number of people
usually find they find from like Sigma
is a measure of risk aversion and when
they measure that they find something
like that
so take those numbers trust me there are
standard numbers and then the last thing
is what is odd and I want to say that in
in we looked at data last time where it
said that people were borrowing at
eighty percent a year
if you borrowing at eighty percent a
year you have an asset that's exactly
like having an asset which pays 80
percent a year because if I borrowed one
dollar less I would pay one dollar
eighty cent less on it so anybody who
has an asset which has an interest rate
of 80% is sitting on an asset with an
eighty percent interest rate on it
there's exactly the same thing I just
pay one dollar a borrow one dollar less
so anybody has a loan off which is
paying eighty percent is exactly like
having an asset which has eighty percent
on it so now I plug that in so think of
somebody who has a loan who's who's
borrowing at 80 percent 67 percent of
the people yeah we saw that actually
last time
well borrowing had loans and the average
interest rate was 80% so you know this
is this is not unreasonable these
numbers so let's take those numbers plug
them in and you get you get consumption
growth will be 17% per year
that's a huge growth rate that would say
poverty would vanish in five years
because you know 17% for a year is a
very very fast growth rate what's the
logic here say these guys they have an
investment opportunity which pays 80% a
year they're not using it so there must
be the only reason you don't use any
investor opportunity that's paying that
much is that you know you're going to be
much richer in the future so you don't
want to invest otherwise you should use
this opportunity so people were
forward-looking and they had an
investment opportunity which paid their
80% a year they should be pumping all
their money into the future eighty
percent a year is a great investment
opportunity only people who would do it
or people are getting rich very fast
because you're getting rich very fast
then you don't want consumption in the
future so that says that though within
if we take the assume people are
rational then the fact that people are
persistently borrowing I'll show you
this in a minute in much I'm not making
this example up so I'll show you the
problem in a minute the fact that people
are persistently borrowing at eighty
percent a year means that they must be
getting rich very fast but in other
words since they're not getting rich
very fast the poor seem to remain poor
something's wrong with this calculation
so we're gonna try to figure out what's
wrong with it but if I take the model
seriously and say this is how people
saved it's clear that it's implication
is that the poverty should be vanishing
phenomenon
because basically you know these guys
have such a wonderful investment
opportunity you should just you can just
save at 80 percent a year and get a lot
richer so that's yeah Sigma is equal to
3 that comes from Sigma Z is actually so
Sigma is the coefficient of risk
aversion it turns out that that's what's
going if we look at the utility function
and you look at we're given that utility
function how would people react to risk
that will be measured by Sigma so you
can actually look at how people actually
react to risks I offer you you know $10
for sure or you know $4 with probability
1/3 and $15 with probability 2/3 and I
see how you whether you want that bet or
not
and from that people back out the risk
aversion I mean they do that they get a
number like 3 so this is sort of a hint
at what's going on and I want to show
you some kind of something more worried
so here's an experiment so it's kind of
get is a different way of getting at the
same point I got showed it to you kind
of theoretically don't show it to you as
an experiment here's an experiment
experiment with fruit vendors and
vegetable vendors in India and the
Philippines two separate experiments
doing identical things so fruit vending
is a very very simple production
function very very simple meaning you
buy fruits in the morning you sell all
day you get money money and in the
evening you go home next morning you
come back and you BA buy fruit again you
sell it it's a it's very predictable
very continuous daily production very
not very high risk actually it's mostly
you know you know what you can sell you
can see the price etc so here's a table
which kind of summarizes a bit the about
these people so most of these people
make one trip a day to the market this
is this one's for the Indian experiment
they buy fruits worth about a thousand
rupees in the morning they sell it and
they get profits over 100 rupees that's
the ten percent profits during a day not
bad actually how do they run the
business 70 percent take a loan every
day every month twenty-six days somebody
takes a loan so dubai this is to buy
fruit the interest rate on the loan per
day is five percent basically the way it
works is you go to the fruit seller and
he says you want to buy cash or credit
cash price is this credit price is that
which one's higher credit price is
higher right it's like if I basically
you get the same fruit so you pay more
if you buy buy it in credit but the
advantage of credit you don't have to
pay for it in the morning you paid it in
the night you go back and you in the
evening you pay for it five percent a
day most of these people have been in
yeah can wecan so most of these people
have been in know this is a missing one
table these most of these people have
been in business for nine years they do
this day after day nine years they've
been in business every day they borrow
at five percent meaning that they come
in the morning they take what they
thousand rupees worth of fruits but they
actually get nine fifty rupees worth of
fruits and then they go sell it
they say I'm going to this is a thousand
rupees but in fact get nine fifty rupees
worth of fruits that they go sell it
remember that daily income is about
hundred rupees they pay 50 rupees out of
thousand is interest so they're paying
there if they didn't pay interest their
earnings every day would be fifty
percent higher they would go for hundred
two hundred and fifty roughly so that's
a huge interest cost now here's a way to
think about five percent and a what it
means suppose I took this our following
strategy drink one less cup of tea every
day a cup of tea costs in this same
currency two and a half rupees so let me
take one less cup every day and I
reinvest that in the business so what I
do is instead of I drink one less cup of
tea
so I borrow two and a half rupees less
today that's that means I don't pay
interest on the two and a half rupees so
I get a little bit extra money and
reinvest that I do that for thirty days
every day ice I don't I drink one less
cup of tea for thirty days that'll
double my at five percent a day you
should do this calculation stunning
compound interest really is impressive
so once you do this but for thirty days
you would have doubled you would have
doubled your capital so these women
could double their capital by simply
having one less cup of tea every day for
30 days they've been in this business
for nine years they're paying fifty
percent they're earning fifty percent no
the earnings will be fifty percent more
if they did this they could pay down
their entire thousand rupees debt by
doing that for thirty days
basically so the your thousand rupees
are essentially just the price of you
know 30 days worth of tea so what that
what that's so that's sort of stunning
if you think about it even so this goes
back to the same point I was trying to
make which is that there's some reason
to get worried that these people are
somehow you know they're not managing
this experiment what they're trying to
do in this experiment is they offer two
treatments they they basically think
they're two possible ways in which we
could maybe one possibility is that
these people and now they need a
thousand rupees to survive a hundred
rupees to eat every day so they can't
save and so they're stuck so you know
that you if you could it's not clear why
they couldn't have one cup of tea less
that's that's not a question but so they
they say well maybe if we just pay their
debt so let's say they over thousand
rupees will give them a thousand rupees
you know imagine that there's some
reason they can't get out of it do they
stay out of debt if I pay them a
thousand rupees second possibility is
that I teach them what compound interest
is I explain to them that you know if
you just did this you would get you know
you could save yourself a lot of money
so they're two treatments they're
experimental so some of them get one
don't get other some of them get both so
do you see what the experiment is I
either go to someone and say you all the
the food seller a thousand rupees here's
a thousand rupees you're done now from
now on you start from scratch or I go to
them and say come to a class I'll
explain to you
compound interest or your or I offer
them
so what happens so that's the question
you know so some people some of these
people for some reason they had got into
this debt let's say they've been
liberated from the debt
some people were educated on this Kippur
the arithmetic or compound interest
so the training was half a day training
where they were explained how much they
spent on interest all these
illustrations if you saved just one cup
of tea every day will be enough etc all
of that skip so here's the here's a
result this one's from the this one's
from the let's see which which countries
this is Philippines from Phil from the
Philippines here's the basic result post
times payoff says if you were ignore
what everything else that says but just
look at what it says do you have a debt
the question is do you have a debt from
a money lender after two weeks that
number says you are 33% less likely to
have a debt for one lender after two two
weeks so two weeks after I pay your
entire thousand rupees down you're back
to having a loan for five percent a day
so 67 percent so 33 percent don't have a
loan so 67 percent have a loan after two
weeks after six weeks
sixty percent have a loan after ten
weeks 80 percent have a loan
so basically by ten weeks every that
thousand rupees that they had been given
just vanishes they don't seem to be able
to stay out of debt the same results are
true for and this is this is the India
study so debt payoff
after a first follow up after three
months eighty so ten percent so this 10
percent negative ten percent don't have
a loan so 90 percent after three months
have got back alone so even though these
people were the loan was paid down that
went away within so three months and the
training just to had nothing there was
no effect of training you can see that's
people were trained if you look at the
training row that row says nothing
significant in that row that's just
saying that post times training is the
effect of if you are hired a training
what's the probability you have a loan
it's exactly it's positive meaning
you're more likely to have a loan but
it's certainly not significant so it's
basically no effect or whether they be
alone or not so the fact that you were
explained compound interest seems to
have no effect on whether you get a loan
or not it's it's kind of stunning to do
this
how are people slipping why are they
getting back into so one thing that you
find is that when they get any sharks
like somebody gets sick if if you have
your debt was paid off so that you were
given the money you are much more likely
to steal the shark by with your own
money rather than by borrowing so what
these people are doing is they seem to
be using the money to deal with sharks
so basically there's so much uncertainty
in these people's lives that every is
always something that comes up and when
that comes up you use the money to deal
with the problem and then you back back
borrowing basically so that's I will
start to think about what these results
mean on on Tuesday okay so we'll think
about them do the reading we'll talk
more about interesting